A lot of folks are understandably ready to
pull the plug on 2016.
But before you pop the champagne,
here are 5 things Libertarians should be nervous about in the new year.
At a time when most Americans support legalization,
2017 could be bad news for those in favor of legal weed.
Though Trump has said legalization should
be up to the states,
he's been appointing anti-marijuana law makers to key positions in his cabinet.
Most notable of these is Alabama senator Jeff
Sessions who's been tapped as Attorney General.
Sessions has long opposed legalization and
has criticized both the Obama administration
and the Department of Justice for not enforcing
federal marijuana laws.
I mean we need grown-ups in charge in Washington
to say marijuana is not the kind of thing that ought to be legalized.
When Donald Trump is sworn into office,
he'll be inheriting a debt that has nearly doubled under President Obama.
In early 2017 the national debt is set to
hit a staggering 20 trillion dollars.
But don't expect the new administration to
make America's fiscal nightmare great again.
Estimates from the Committee for a Responsible Budget
say Trump's policy proposals will add another 5.3 trillion dollars over the next four years.
Globalization and free trade have lifted millions
out of poverty
and raised living standards across the United States.
Yet we enter 2017 with both Democrats and
Republicans
questioning the fundamental value of free markets.
A new administration promising to inject itself
into the affairs of private companies
and a President openly threatening a costly trade
war with China.
It's now clear that so-called fake news can
have real world consequences.
Those consequences now include Facebook now
testing new plugins to limit misinformation
and partnering with fact checking groups to
root out any false news items,
causing fears of censorship on the popular social media platform.
When policy makers and politicians start pressuring
private companies to limit speech,
expect trouble.
The FBI, NSA and CIA are most likely going
to get shiny new surveillance powers
under a Trump administration.
Now some of these changes are already happening.
A new rule approved this fall allows federal
agents with a single search warrant
to hack millions of American's computers or smart
phones at once.
And it's not just Uncle Sam, the United Kingdom
just approved the Investigatory Powers bill,
which gives the UK's global surveillance program
authorities power
to create a new government database
that will store the web history of
every citizen in the country.
So by all means say goodbye to 2016, but don't
let your guard down,
there'll be plenty to be nervous about in the new year.